>>> RUIA IS ISSUING A NEW
THREAT TO UKRAINE AND SO TO
THE UNITED STATES.
FOLLOWING THE REPORTING THAT T
U.S. IS FINALIZI PLANS TO SHIP
A PATRIOT MISSILE SYSTEM TO
UKRAINE, THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT
IS NOW WARNING THAT MOVE COULD,
QUOTE, LEAD TO UNPREDICTABLE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
HERE WITH ME NOW, CNN MILITARY
ANALYST JAMES SPIDER MARKS.
IT IS GOOD TO HAVE YOU HERE.
YOU COULD TALK ABOUT THE RUSSIAN
RESPONSE, THE UNPREDICTABLE
CIRCUMSTANCES OR CONSEQUENCES.
WHY IS RUSSIA SAYING THAT.
>> WELL THEY'VE USE TAD
TERMINOLOGY BEFORE RELATIVE TO
THEIR THREAT TO USE NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
I THINK THAT THEY'RE SAYING IN
THIS CASE IS THAT THE EMPLOYMENT
OF THE PATRIOT WHICH IS UPGRADED
AIR DEFENSE ABILITY WILL
DIMINISH THE ABILITY,IB
KRUSINGLY THE DRONES THAT ARE
GUIDES TO GO AFTER A VERY
SENSITIVE TARGET, INFRASTRUCTURE
AND CITIZEN LOCATIONS AND THINGS
LIKE THAT.
BUT THE RUSSIAS HAVE BEEN
LAUNCHING THOSE TO SANCTUARY,
FROM BOMBERS OVER RUSSIA FROM
CASPIAN SEA TO THEIR TRACKING
INTO UKRAINE AND THE S-400 WHICH
IS THE SYSTEM THEY MOVE NOW
WHICH IS FORMER SOVIET, WHICH IS
NOT AS CAPABLE.
>> SO EXPLAIN THE PATRIOT
MISSILE SYSTEM.
WHY THAT IS MORE THREATENING OR
JUST A BETTER SYSTEM FULL STOP?
>> IT IS.
IT INCREASES ACCURACY, IT
INCREASES THE KILL RATE.
SO IT REALLY DOES EXACTLY WHAT
YOU WANT IT TO DO, WHICH IS
PROTECTION ON THE GROUND ON VERY
SPECIFIC TARGETS.
THE S-400 COULD DO THAT BUT THE
FLEXIBILITY OF THE PATRIOT GIVES
IT GREAT ACCURACY AND GREAT
PRECISION WITHOUT HAVING TO
REPOSITION THE RADAR.
THAT IS A LITTLE INSIDE BUT IT
MAKES IT MUCH MORE FLEXIBLE AND
THE ACCURACY HAS GONE UP AND THE
RUSSIANS HAVE LOST THE ADVANTAGE
OF LAUNCHING FROM SANCTUARY.
SO THE RUSSIANS NOW HAVE TO GO
BACK TO DUMB ROCKS ARTILLERY
WHICH MEANS THEY'LL HAVE TO GET
IN CLOSER TO THE UKRAINIANS AND
EVERY TIME THEY CLOSE WITH
UKRAINIAN FORCES, YOU KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS.
THEY GET SLAUGHTERED.
SO THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
>> IF THIS IS A SMARTER, MORE
EFFICIENT AND BETTER WEAPON FOR
UKRAINE TO DEFEND ITSELF, WHAT
DO YOU THINK OF THE FACT THAT
THEIR SENDING IT OVER JUST NOW?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
CAN'T GET INTO THE HEAD OF THE
ADMINISTRATION.
I KNOW THERE ARE POLITICAL,
THERE ARE ALLIANCE
CONSIDERATIONS, OF COURSE, THAT
OVERARCH ALL OF THIS.
THE PATRIOT IS AN UPGRADE.
WHY IT WASN'T USED EARLY ON AS
RUSSIA DEMONSTRATE AND WE NOW
THE RUSSIANS FIGHT.
THEY GOT INTO FIGHTS AND THEY'RE
UP FRONT AND PERSONAL TACTICAL
FLIGHTS AND THEY WERE GETTING
SLAUGHTER AND THEY BACK OFF AND
USE MISSILES AND NOW INCREASING
THE USE OF DRONES.
WHERE THE PATRIOTS WEREN'T THERE
ALL ALONG.
IT IS A GAME OF CHESS.
BUT IT IS NOT CHECK MATE, BUT IT
IS CHECK.
>> OREN LIEBERMANN IS REPORTING
FOR THE FIRST TEAM A FULL TIME
COMMAND SER TAKING OVER U.S.
OPERATIONS TO TRAIN AND ARM
UKRAINIAN FORCES.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> WELL IT IS A MILITARY
ASSISTANCE COMMAND AND IN THE
HISTORY OF THE U.S. ARMY AND ALL
OF THE SERVICES, WE'VE HAD THESE
MILITARY ASSISTANT, WE HAVE
MAC-V IN VIETNAM AND JUST MAG K
AND ALL OF DIFFERENT GROUPS FOR
CAREER. WE HAVE ONE IN SYRIA.
SO WHAT THIS GIVES IS THE
SEPARATION BETWEEN THE
INDIVIDUAL THAT HAS TO EXECUTE
THE TRAINING AND THE POTENTIAL
FIGHTING AND THE ASSESSMENT OF
HIS OR HER CAPABILITIES ON
GROUND, AND THEN YOU PUT IT IN
THE HANDS OF THIS ASSISTANCE
GROUP, THE COORDINATION AND THE
PLANNING AND DELIVERY AND
WORKING WITH OTHER NATIONS SO
THAT THAT INDIVIDUAL COULD
DELIVER TO THE POTENTIAL
COMBATANT COMMANDER.
SO IT MAKES IT MUCH MO